by tonight we start with a bombshell
development about former deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe Fox News Tonight
reporting that the Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is reviewing a recommendation
from the FBI's Office of Professional
Responsibility to give McCade the axe
and sources are telling Fox News that
firing McCabe before Friday get this
would mean he would lose his
taxpayer-funded pension he's set to
retire on Sunday something explosive has
gone on here now this new development is
raising speculation that the DOJ is
inspector general's report about the
FBI's phony Clinton email investigation
where the fix was in that that could be
released soon and Fox News has learned
that the Inspector General's
investigation has discovered that McCabe
was not forthcoming about his approval
for an FBI official to talk to reporters
about the bureau's investigation into
the Clinton Foundation and according to
reports this scandal is what forced
McCabe to be removed from that position
and placed on leave and according to a
Wall Street Journal report from earlier
this year
McCabe waited an entire month to inform
Congress remember those thousands of uma
Abidine emails that were found on
anthony Weiner's laptop why would he
wait then of course there's the text
message from the Trump hating FBI lovers
Peter struck and leased a page now where
remember they've mentioned talking to
Andy we think that's Andrew McCabe about
that insurance policy god forbid if
Donald Trump won the election and by the
way you have McCabe's wife Jill she took
over $700,000 in political contributions
from Hillary Clinton's ally Terry
McAuliffe and another Democratic group
for a failed Virginia state Senate run
an obscene amount of money so when it
comes to firing Andrew McCabe the
Attorney General jeff Sessions should
not be contemplating a decision here
because the answer is obvious and the
facts are staring sessions right in the
face
mccabe is corrupt and he is as crooked
as they come he is one of those deep
state actors that we have been telling
you about and he needs to be held
accountable and firing McCabe by the way
should only be a start we know for a
fact James Comey Peter struck Lisa Paige
other top FBI officials put
to fix in and they ignored overwhelming
incontrovertible evidence that Hillary
Clinton in fact committed multiple
felonies Clinton should have been
prosecuted she never should have made it
to November of 2016 it was an
open-and-shut case the evidence was all
there it didn't happen the fix was in it
was rigged
and that's why McCabe Comey struck page
and all the other top FBI officials that
played a hand in this sham of an
investigation into Clinton they should
be terrified tonight about this DOJ
Inspector General report that we expect
to come out any day now now criminal
referrals should also be made to the DOJ
and if you believe in equal justice
under the law all of these deep state
officials they all need to be prosecuted
all right also brand-new tonight liberal
hypocrisy reaches a stunning new level
take a look at this video
there he is socialist senator Bernie
Sanders you know working his way through
an anti Second Amendment rally on the
steps of the US Capitol but notice oh
he's surrounded by armed security guys
now Bernie Sanders was not alone
we have other gun grabbing liberal
politicians they all showed up to speak
out against your Second Amendment rights
to keep and bear arms and also
predictably attack the NRA take a look
our congressional solitary walk up is to
here to say enough is enough we need a
vote now we need a vote
and it's common sense that we should get
the assault rifles and the banana clips
off the streets the NRA has made me
public enemy number one and I'm proud of
it we are gonna win I want to know are
you prepared to do whatever it takes to
beat the gun lobby are we gonna ban
assault weapons are we going to have
universal background checks unbelievable
and then there's the anti Second
Amendment Crusader New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo who actually participated
in a die-in
in a protest in New York City take a
look
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah he has tons of security also just
shameless hypocrites they stand in front
of crowds of people no fear about their
own personal safety because they are
surrounded by armed security but they
would deny those same protections to
America's schoolchildren does that make
any sense by the way here's a quick
question if being protected by armed
police officers is good for these
politicians shouldn't be good for our
children in America schools
pretty simple answer right anybody way
have you noticed that congressional
Democrats they are always the champions
of gun-free zones
except places where they work there's
tons of security at the Capitol and the
same goes for Hollywood liberals now
those pompous award ceremonies have more
security than Fort Knox but in their
minds it's outrageous for schools to
take the same precautions that they have
you want to protect America's schools
and our kids the solutions are obvious I
have highlighted them on this show you
need comprehensive threat security
assessments you need control points of
entry you need to secure the perimeters
you need school IDs metal detectors and
yes concealed carry armed highly trained
retired former police and military now
by the way the house did take a step
forward today they overwhelmingly passed
a school safety bill that Awards grant
money to States to help train teachers
and students and law enforcement
officials to stop the violence in
schools it's a good start but it's not
good enough America's schools our kids
deserve the same security that liberals
demand for themselves all right also
tonight the acting director of ice
slamming Nancy Pelosi for daring if you
can believe it to call federal
immigration authorities that risk their
lives every single day to keep this
country safe Nancy called them cowardly
watch this not only to say they were
cowardly she said that you know ice was
terrorizing immigrant communities first
of all you're talking about law
enforcement officers these are men and
women that put their lives on the line
this country every day they strap a gun
to their head and leave the safety and
security of their homes to defend this
nation so how dare you call them
cowardly and to say that were were
terrorizing American communities that
people we arrested during these
California operations looting this
the city of attacks with the juvenile
assault with deadly weapons murder these
people were terrorizing immigrant
communities
I went in there and remove these people
from the communities so liberals like
Nancy Pelosi they're making it clear
they have no problem putting American
lives in danger to protect criminal
illegal immigrants and I'm not talking
about daca I'm not talking about
dreamers or people that have benefited
from chain migration or the Visa Lottery
but these liberals like the Oakland
California mayor mayor liberal
what's-her-name Libby Schaaf they're
aiding and abetting criminal illegal
immigrants those that have caused real
harm to real American citizens and real
American families so it's hard to
imagine how anyone could defend doing
this but of course the left is and we
watch it every day and that's why you
have angel parents those are people
whose children were killed by illegal
immigrants they are now rightly
demanding that mayor shaft face
prosecution for obstruction of justice
protecting criminals aiding and abetting
people that shouldn't be in the country
in the first place and then commit other
crimes and liberals like to pretend that
illegal immigrants don't commit crimes
but they're lying when they say that and
sadly these angel parents are needlessly
suffering all because of this it's a
national disgrace it can be stopped and
if it happens again those people
protecting them they are the ones to
blame
now also tonight liberals are channeling
their rage to attack a brand new target
see the woman on the screen they're
Democrats are now threatening to block
the nomination of Gina Hass Bell to be
the first female CIA director now here's
why hospital played a very key role in
overseeing the enhanced interrogation
techniques that were used at CIA black
sites against top-level al Qaeda
terrorists of course this is after 9/11
3,000 Americans were killed and the left
can feign all the moral outrage they
want play all the politics they want but
facts are not on their side
the CIA other top officials like Leon
Panetta who worked in the Obama
administration have said and we'll show
you this later tonight that enhanced
interrogation techniques they worked and
it led to finding and killing Osama bin
Laden without them he probably would
still be alive today and people like
Hospital
literally saved American lives in that
sense she's a patriot Democrats should
not put partisan petty politics ahead of
your national security of course we
would have preferred not to have been
attacked on 9/11 but sadly we all know
evil does exist evil must be defeated
radical Islamist came here all right
finally tonight I have a message to
congressional Republicans after last
night's special election in the 18th
district of Pennsylvania GOP members of
Congress take a good long look in the
mirror because that could be your future
and if it happens you'll have nobody to
blame but yourselves
now you can't put aside the fact that
this was an interesting case because the
Democrat Connor Lam really pretended to
be pro life pro second amendment and
even Pro Trump and anti Pelosi so he was
kind of acting like a Republican and
he's quickly gonna fall in line with
whatever Nancy Pelosi tells him to do
watch and see
but what happened last night should
serve as a warning to all Republicans
you want to be successful in 2018
there's a simple solution keep all of
the promises you make in campaign years
it's really that simple
that's the best politics make the
country safer
give us a great economy go back to your
district look your voters in the eye and
tell them that you did what you said you
were going to do now you've already
passed tax cuts check good job but you
also promised to repeal and replace
Obamacare and you also most of you
promise to build the wall so now is your
opportunity it's March you have until
November to follow through show some
backbone show some vision mean what you
say say what you mean finish the job on
Obamacare and start building the wall
now if you do that my guess is I've only
been at this thirty years
voters are gonna reward you and if you
don't do it they probably won't